the scene is one of utter Devastation
here it's one of the hardest if not the
hardest hit area in the whole of turkey
and we're talking in comparative terms
where every area is so badly hit and you
can see they are there are now scores
and scores and scores of people taking
part in this search and rescue effort
they're spending a lot of time clearing
a lot of the debris away there's a great
deal of tension in the area because many
of the residents are extremely angry
that it's taken so long to get a
substantial coordinated or
semi-coordinated effort help relief
effort here to this area and so far
unfortunately all we have seen is them
retrieving corpses we
saw a line of them I would say maybe
half a dozen body bags and other bodies
put under blankets which are laid out in
a clearing some of them have got labels
on them
and relatives are sort of coming up and
checking the label every now and again
and one man who saw and recognized the
label just utterly crumpled in front of
it and is now sitting just next to this
this body bag crying I'm refusing to
leave it is a really heart-wrenching
scene have a look at this okay and all
your viewers is that another building
every building around here is maybe not
entirely toppled like uh this one it was
just pretty destroyed that that Jake's
focusing on right now but right next to
it is another residential area and you
can see the the trail of tied together
sheets as people have tried to scramble
out presumably when the first Quake hit
now they believe many relatives we've
seen sort of gathering around here they
believe there are still their loved ones
inside there and they keep on telling us
that they're hearing sounds and that's
why they're there's still this certain
amount of desperation another
um just a vision that I want to show you
is look look at all these these rescue
workers here now they were just not here
12 14 hours ago when we were last here
so they have really poured a great deal
of effort into this and we've heard
residents complaining that they've had
to to shout and scream and stamp to get
attention for this area one one woman
saying why did we have to cry why did we
because the the social media platforms
were Awash with please when we were here
earlier they were yesterday they were
coming up to us complaining saying we
need help we need help we need help we
saw a volunteer truck they driven a van
full of donations food donations
clothing donations and they were handing
it out to a crowd who were utterly
desperate hands reaching out grabbing
the things fights breaking out as they
were scrapping over warm clothing
mothers crying saying I need this I've
got children I need this more than you
it really is a desperate situation